ici l'affluence n'a pas beaucoup diminué
ces dernières semaines les salariés du
techn'hom de belfort sont environ 160
chaque midi à venir déjeuner dans ce
restaurant avec ou sans pas sanitaires
j'ai mon passani terre donc s'ils me le
demande je présenterai ça ne pose pas de
problème pour ça un petit peu injuste
parce que pour certains on le demande
alors que pour d'autres on ne demande
pas et je trouve ça un peu choquant et
si cet établissement n'est pas soumis au
contrôle du pass sanitaire c'est parce
qu'il est conventionnée avec les
entreprises du secteur alstom general
electric ou orange par exemple si nous
on est soumis au passé ni tard il va
falloir aussi que les entreprises de sa
semi donc là ça y est c'est 30 et relax
et je pense pas forcément passer pour
toutes les entreprises après c'est ça
serait vraiment très compliqué à faire
puisque après il faut faire aussi un
contrôle en amont aussi quand les gens
vous diraient m'en irai travail et pas
forcément venu prêcher nous pour
l'instant aucune contrainte donc pour
adam qui n'est pas vacciné ce qui
n'empêche pas de déjeuner ce midi avec
son ancien collègue vincent qui dispose
lui d'un pass annie terre c'est un choix
voilà donc classé viennent pour venir
manger quand même sympa sanitaires c'est
son choix j'ai fait le lien après aucun
souci à ce niveau te faut vivre avec le
virus maintenant donc on va pas de
ségrégation entre personnes tout
simplement et avec l'élargissement des
contrôles au lieu de culture et aux
terrasses le restaurant d'entreprise et
finalement l'un des rares lieux de
brassage entre vacciner et non vaccinés
c'est un des rares endroits
effectivement sauf que sont soumis à un
protocole sanitaire donc il conserve le
mas tant qu'ils ne sont pas à table
c'est après une fois qu'ils sont à table
que la question peut se poser est ce
qu'il ya risque ou pas et ça on n'a pas
encore assez de recul pour le savoir
aujourd'hui malheureusement s'il est
normalement réservé aux seuls salariés
du techn'hom l'établissement tient à le
préciser ici pas question de devenir un
repaire de ceux qui ne disposeraient pas
encore d'un pas saine